there were two seismic events this week
first the death of Teresa Mays deal
second it became clear that Parliament
is now at war with the people in governs
never has there been a more shameless
undemocratic unprincipled bunch of
shysters in Parliament politicians who
piously bang on about the national
interest while doing everything in their
power to damage it divisions over breaks
that have spewed up an arrogant
political class totally insulated from
the lives of the people they represent
MPs who believe their vote and their
views matter more than ours they've
forgotten what democracy means and
associated with their own power not ours
as demonstrated by Dominic Lehman his
cabal of arrogant remaineth who are now
preparing to tear up the parliamentary
rule book to seize control of braixen
I'm glad you bet you think it's funny
these saboteurs are arrogant enough to
believe the power we afforded them
allows them to silence our voice trash
our vote and render the government
powerless so it's not just brexit on the
line here it's democracy together with
our whole political system and if they
fail anarchy
will follow the Laughing cry and I love
you Carol and so I'd rather laughed and
and then get angry on you because what
you said I don't agree with much of what
you just said I'm sure I'll explain why
I don't agree parliamentary sovereignty
in the doctrine of parliamentary
sovereignty which was the fundamental
pillar of the brexit campaign that very
doctor in parliamentary sovereignty
teaches us in constitutional law which
donít grieve by the way has is you know
he understands the law are you mentioned
him this why I refer to him and that is
that Parliament can do what it wants a
no pass Parliament can bind a future
Parliament this is a fundamental pillar
of our Constitution and he's trying to
do that the rules of it and Parliament
can the Parliament can legislate to
govern itself over its own rules as well
Parliament can pretty much do what it
wants in this country that is the term
you think that's a good thing no no let
me continue with that we also beyond
that point have a representative
democracy not a
direct democracy and as a result it
means that our MPs can lead their
constituency for five years and then go
back to their constituents to ask for a
verdict on how they performed they are
not obliged to adhere to even the
majority opinion in their constituents
let me let me add last point I'll make
in response to you and that is that that
we have the referendum itself the
Parliament legislated for and approved
legally it is advisory and the reason I
mentioned that not that you don't have a
model I never tell there you won no you
won the vote the only reason I mentioned
that it was legally advisory is to touch
from the what i with respect consider a
tad hyperbolic that this would be
anarchy in the end of democracy because
if the referendum was only advisory then
it's not the end of democracy if it
isn't adhere to though of course morally
it should be adhere to so I make all of
those okay just to say okay so in the
rhetoric you're talking about Parliament
was not peaceable okay let me answer you
there stronger than that okay so in the
last in the last election before the
last election in 2017 more than 80% of
our politicians made a solemn vow to
implement an honor the result of the
referendum many of them were re-elected
on that very premise and so the minute
they get reelected they change their
mind and now they're trying to over to a
hundred years of history in Parliament
to achieve what they want they're trying
to change the rules to suit their agenda
and and whereas I'm going to come to you
quickly where as you know we pretended
this is a in the national interest and
it's about parliamentary sovereignty
it's naked now all they want to do is
whatever it takes to stop breaks it I do
I think the art of this convoy is how
things people keep saying then looking
after their own interests I don't think
they are I think the vast majority of
them are looking at what they find and
saying yeah we should do this what we
shouldn't do this and I think I think
they're taking quite principled position
the problem is that this just amongst
those who want to leave there are two
distinct groups there's one good who
want to leave under World Trade
Organization terms and just get out
there's an other law saying you can't do
that unless you've got a deal this is a
deck anomic disaster for this country
and they then
I agree those two and therefore almost
anything you look at there's no majority
for because of that but I fear for this
sorry usually I was gonna say is I think
your points are fascinating and promptly
absolutely right in all the rest of it
but they're very technical point so what
you're doing is you're saying
representative democracy versus direct
democracy you're saying about oh yeah
this was advisory but not they're not
legally obligated yes the very technical
points but I would say that the man on
the streets he's not six or fewer yeah
he's not sitting that director is
representing he's not he's just saying
listen we had a vote to leave and
whatever you say about advisory it said
in black and white on that little
leaflet that we all got that it said
black and white the government will
implement what you decide it did say
that that's right so it's the man on the
street they can read and they understand
that and they vote and they don't they
don't get into what you're saying about
specifics I feel that they those people
that vote breaks it feel incredibly let
down and this has become a game playing
personal political opportunistic thing
instead of actually implementing what
people ask you know even so whether or
not there will be anarchy in the streets
I'm not sure but what you certainly will
even worry that's a big final I still
believe that many politicians do not
understand and why people voted leave
they think they people voted leave
because they were stupid because of a
site of of course because of rush
interference or because of Facebook
which is no what I'm saying is they
don't understand why people voted Lee if
they have ignored those concepts could
most the time they don't even understand
them and they will just go on you can do
what what I find extraordinary is there
are 650 MPs to whom we pay a minimum of
seventy seven thousand seven hundred
pounds per annum a minimum they get more
as they progress up the ladder and they
have been unable to resolve this they
asked us to give them a decision we gave
them a decision they failed to implement
that to keep the numbers going that is
because the current constitution of the
House of Commons is around 67 percent
remain I find it personally sickening
although I think you've gone a little
bit over the top with mr. grieve and I
think you perhaps painted him in too
good a color but I find it extraordinary
man who actually represents a leave
constituency all by 0.7 percent but it's
still a leave would seem to be the prime
architect in denying leave the bottom
line is this I don't
do it again if you do it again do you
honestly think the British equivalent of
the Rust Belt do you think their lives
have improved in the last two-and-a-half
years they are still watching this
program in black fur and in Sunderland
and in Leeds in fact they're probably
even worse bloody often they were two
and a half years ago all you will do is
heat more division who should decide it
was sort of debating this one who should
decide it the people we pay an absolute
fortune to and they should be had their
heads banged together and find a company
you've just mentioned the Greve leads a
bit marginally yet with all the main
remain as all these rebels all of them
represent leave considers and and you
say that you know there's not going to
be anarchy it's if these MPs together
with Bercow succeed in the government
can no longer independently manage the
business of Parliament then Parliament
will fall and we will have sorry because
I've been waiting government doesn't
it's not the job of government to manage
part of it of Parliament of Parliament
it's not the job of government to manage
Parliament's the job of Parliament to
manage government is the other way
around
that's what parliamentary sovereignty
means I do agree with what Michelle said
that actually it's about feelings and
people feel betrayed which is what I
said you have the moral high ground and
my points are technical but the reason I
don't think they'll be unrest and
anarchy and civil war or anything like
that is we've been here before we were
incredibly let down when Tony Blair
invaded Iraq as a country but it didn't
lead to apart from terrorists were now
in jail it didn't lead to the breakdown
of our democracy we've been here before
feelings are strong across the board but
I believe our countries stronger than to
break apart are this over this dispute
let me take a clip from John Bercow
because I think John Peron got it right
his job is to defend democracy not to
defend the executive I have no intention
of taking lectures on doing right by
Parliament's from people who have been
conspicuous in denial of and sometimes
contempt for it I will stand up for the
rights of the House of Commons
and I will not be pushed around by
agents of the executive branch I mean
that's why of course there's a whole
chunk of the conservative party who in
government who hate him because he's
he's the first speaker certainly that I
can remember who's actually stood up and
said now this is a democracy and you all
get a vote we discuss this before but he
did to finally vice he didn't realize he
okay he said what I said it don't want
said precedent has to be changed oh set
up before you go through